when you hit puberty your father in
India
had to put bars on the Windows of your
house guys would follow you home I need
to be that level high Priyanka to the
point that your father has to start
putting bars on the window let me just
no give me let me give you contact
imagine you're that hot what a blessing
my dad was super paranoid because he
sent to America a 12 year old
you know with braids and like trying to
be cool so I got my hair blown out that
was the only thing I'd ever done come
back after all of these American
hormones in the food I come back like
you know a little bit more woman than my
dad would have anticipated at 16. how
did your father put the bars on the
window like did he hire a company to
come in yes yes he did and did you did
you say Dad what's going on here why are
there bars it was scary like this is one
of those moments that you're talking
about when I went back to India and I
was in this small town and I was
peacocking like I peacock in my American
High School I had boys follow me home
and one of them jumped into my balcony
at night and that's why my dad was like
[__] this bars all your jeans are
confiscated you're gonna wear Indian
Suits nothing happening like I had a
driver drive me everywhere like he was
freaked out so I get it I get it and but
then my career your poor father your
poor father I mean men following you I
mean I don't know what the hell I would
do I feel so bad for my dad because like
I would
he was like you're gonna wear loose
clothes or you're gonna wear Indian
clothes so I was like all right I don't
have any loose clothes I would take his
shirts his favorite shirts tie them up
and wear the jeans and like open out
buttons in this small town in India
where boys are fun like I didn't
understand the gravity of it I thought I
was invincible in my 20s
like I think about it now
how did I get away with the [__] that I
did all of us I think but it was just
this invincible thing of I can get away
with anything and
but that day when somebody was outside
of my bedroom
it was was this a guy you knew no or you
didn't even know you didn't even know
this guy no and now he's camped out
outside your bedroom outside my balcony
and I saw it and I screamed and I went
to my dad and
my dad came in and he jumped and he went
away and like the next day it was my dad
was like this you need rules you know I
was so arrogant and vain in those two
years of my life when I and especially
when I came back to India because now
there was suddenly this equity on me
which I didn't have in American High
School where the girls were bullying me
but I came back to the small town and
everyone was like
I've seen how she dresses she went oh I
could imagine she has all my sunglasses
she's wearing FUBU only rappers wear
FUBU you know oh in India you must have
been quite this sensation with the kids
you were all Americanized and like uh
I'm leaning into it
yeah
foreign